hello everyone and welcome back to the
chess 24 legends of chess tournament we
are entering the finals
which means the final four uh are
battling it out to see who will uh win
the the main prize peter swiller magnus
cross and yanni pomsche and anishigiri
and this is the first game of the match
between peter swiddler and magnus
carlsen already quite the
uh quite the beauty so without further
ado let's check it out and
a lot of you have said that uh now with
my new uh
new setup that the sound of the pieces
is much lower so i've increased
it by by some 10 decibels i i do hope
it's okay now if
if it still needs more uh do say
something and
i'm going to try and make it as it was
so let's check it out swiddler with the
white pieces opens with c4 he goes for
the english opening
and the magnus replies with knight to f6
we have knight to c3 e5
and now g3 the carlos bremen system
something that we've seen on this
channel quite a lot uh recently
we've bishop to b4 and now uh e4
and uh we usually uh mention we have
this we had this position like in the in
the previous 20 videos i think we had
like
three or four times uh you cannot win a
pawn here by capturing and then
capturing because just queen e2
and then black will have to give back
the e5 pawn so here bishop captures on
c3 by magnus
uh not going after the pawn but this is
the most played move in this position
and now usually black will capture with
the d-pawn however here swiller captures
with the b-pawn
and this has been played only once in a
game between uh evgeny bareilles and
rustam kassinjanov
uh uh and here we have castles by magnus
and now bishop to g2 was the game
was the move that was played in that
game but here swiller goes for f3
and it is already as of move six that we
have a completely new game and it's
quite a
quite a weird pawn structure here at
some point white will of course strike
in the center with uh
with uh d4 but his king is still in the
center of the board
without any of the pieces actually being
developed so let's see what
swiddler has in mind here rook to e8
by magnus and now comes d4 striking in
the center we have d6
and the bishop to d3 just continuing
development with knight to c6 by magnus
and now knight to e2 this knight the c6
is kind
kind of baiting d5 uh but then black can
even either go knight to e7 to g6 and uh
close the center or or maybe go to
something like a5 and then with b6
bishop a6 put pressure
on the on the c4 pawn so here knight to
e2
as well just continues development and
now b6 by magnus
uh we have g for now here's hillary's
saying that he
he doesn't necessarily uh plant the
castle maybe he's just gonna go uh for
an attack on the king side because
magnus castle very early
but then again it's hard to say how safe
the white king will be in the center of
the board so here magnus goes knight to
d7 he doesn't allow the g5 to come with
with an attack on the knight and also uh
now threatening queen to h4 check which
could be problematic for white
so here swiddler does castle and now
bishop to a6 now now it might be a
problem
to defend this pawn if the knight comes
to a5
hard to say if if uh svidler will be
able to to deal with this
uh he just continues knight to g3 now uh
you might uh
have some knight to f5 ideas from f5 the
h4 square is a guarded you might play h4
all in all it's a very very interesting
position so here
magnus trades once on d4 captures
captures and the knight captures on d4
so he wins upon here
but in return he opens up this diagonal
for svidler's bishop
which of course wheeler immediately sees
it so bishop to b2
and now just knight to e6 so here magnus
won a pawn
but uh yeah svetler is still with the
bishop pair and the dark square bishop
is now
looking looking very nice and here if
magnus can get his knight to f4 is
it will just be a beautiful square for
this knight you're not gonna be able to
kick it away from there easily
so spidler pushes f4 now the pawn is
nicely guarded by the rook here
and now uh well g5 uh sorry f5 is coming
and
there is not much you will be able to do
about that
uh first probably you you will somehow
prevent this knight from coming to g5
and then execute something like f5
but magnus finds a very interesting idea
on on how to do this
he doesn't go h6 or something like that
he instead goes g5
and now the point is if you play f5 now
now uh magnus gets this f4 square for
his knight and black's position is uh
looking wonderful here
he's up a pawn and he has a very active
position
uh so instead uh yeah and even if he
went for something like knight to h5
here just
captures and captures h6 still closes
the position
and you will not be seeing much
attacking here from white's perspective
so instead after g5 svidler finds f
captures on g5
queen captures on g5 and now uh this is
a very
rich position so uh feel free to pause
the video here and
figure out what you would play here with
white while i give you a couple of
seconds
so for those of you who were able to do
it congratulations on spotting this very
very hidden idea and for those of you
who just want to enjoy the show
uh the move here for white is h4 this
beautiful pawn sacrifice which uh
black really shouldn't accept uh however
if he doesn't accept it then you already
have
pawns on h4 and uh and g4
black could decline with queen to c5
check then king h1
and then the game just continues however
what's very interesting is
what happens if the pawn is captured
queen captures an h4
now you get knight f5 with tempo and now
the problem is the h6 square is coming
knight h6 check uh the f7 point will be
under attack
and the problem is if you go something
like queen g5 to keep an eye on the h6
squared then bishop to c1 still
controls the h6 square now we have to
move the queen let's say queen g6 but
now uh if queen g6 now you just trap the
queen knight h6
check you're gonna go king g7 and e5 and
the black queen is trapped uh on the
other hand if you try something like um
after this bishop to see one move if you
bring the queen all the way back it's
not much better just knight h6 checking
is going to move you're going to capture
here with
check king h8 and now e5 and now this is
completely lost there's no way to defend
the h7 pawn
uh if you try something like let's say
you can you can block it with the knight
but then just knight f5 and still
there's too much pressure here captures
captures again white wants to go after
this pawn but now if rook here just
bishop g5 and this is game over
so it was uh an extremely complicated
position and
a really really complicated move this h4
uh and it's uh i i think svidler
mentioned after the game that he
either didn't even consider it uh but
that he should have
that because i mean the position is
crazy and you wanna consider any pawn
sacrifice that is
that is possible to you uh to you know
create some more threats or to get some
attacking chances or even just to
improve the the activity over in your
knight here uh instead
you could also go knight f5 first and
then prepare bishop to c1 kick away the
queen knight f7 check to go for f7 but
svidler first went for rook to f5
uh it's a very nice rook lift however it
gives magnus one move that
would not be available if for example
the knight was on f5 and that is queen
to e3 with
check and now the problem is king h1 and
knight e5
already comes with a double attack here
on the bishop and the white doesn't have
white doesn't have the time to organize
uh some some sort of an attack here
because you first need to react to this
so bishop to e2 by magnus but now bishop
to b7
already now there's a double attack on
this pawn and if this diagonal opens up
it's going to be
well it's just going to be very bad for
for white so here we have queen to c2
adding another defender here but now
knight to c5 adding a triple a a third
attacker here
uh saying that okay now you have no more
options how to how to properly defend
this uh pawn so swiddler goes for the
only only thing left
that's the bishop to c1 attacking the
queen but now magnus just grabs the pawn
he already grabbed one pawn and now he's
going to grab the second one
with bishop captures on c4 so just uh
grabbing that pawn and this comes with
checks so white has to react knight
captures on e4
queen captures a way to check now you
have to trade queens as the queen is
under attack so captures and captures
and all of a sudden we have this
position where white no longer has uh
well attacking chances and he's just
down two points however
he still has the bishop pair so bishop
back to b2
now uh getting the the bishop to this
beautiful diagonal you need to be
somewhat careful here uh but rook to e6
now magnus just prepares to bring the
other rook into the game
rook 8 f1 and now comes rook 8
e8 and the problem here is you cannot
win the f7 pawn for example if you
remove the defender
rook captures and rook captures then the
problem is knight d2
just attacks the rook and also there's
like this double attack on the bishop
here
and the white just completely falls
apart so so instead after rook 88
g5 was played by swiddler now after the
knight moves you will be able to
get this bishop to f6 which would which
would
be problematic for black uh but uh the
problem is magnus just has too many good
moves here magnus played knight to d2
now uh it attacks the rook here and you
have to move the rook so
rook one two f two was played but now
knight e captures on c4 by magnus and it
was in this position on move 27 that
petersfield resigned the game
uh and uh game game one uh went
went to magnus uh here he resigned
because there is nothing to do uh the
bishop is attacked twice
the this uh bishop is attacked here by
the knight
so if you let's say play bishop captures
captures and now
let's say you move this bishop as you
don't want to trade any more pieces
uh you could go let's say bishop to f6
but now just rook to e1
check and now the problem is if you go
here then just knight to e3 check picks
up the rook here on f5
uh or rather if you go rook to f1 white
can just trade captures captures and now
let's say d5
and you have no counter play black is up
three pawns and that's just too much if
rook d1
c6 com the all of the pawns are
completely safe
you're going to get the rook to e2 and
white has zero counterplay here the
bishop is nice here
that that is true but the rook will not
be able to help out with this
uh in in any way uh so yeah after this
knight e captures on c4 swillow resigned
and game one went to magnus and
now i will mention the results of the
other games uh or from this match
as i don't know if we'll be showing any
more of them uh
game two ended by uh by uh
uh being a draw and then in in the third
game where magnus also had the black
pieces magnus again one with the black
pieces and that was enough to
to claim the victory in the first match
so we'll see more matches to come
between the two of them before we decide
the finalists of the uh 24 just 24
legends of chess tournament so uh stay
tuned
sure uh svetler really had uh had a good
position
had he found this h4 move uh it could
have could have gone either way
but he didn't and then after rook to f5
it was just it was just all magnus
so uh once again i do hope you enjoyed
it i would like to thank
juan vincente alvarez glenn mangold
priyam gupta dog mcnabb and colin
cunningham for a contribution to my
channel thank you a lot i really
appreciate it
uh as usual you can check two of my
previous videos here thank you for
watching and i will see you soon
continuing the coverage
of the just wonderful legends tournament
checking up on your wonderful
suggestions
and whatever else happens in the chess
world so thank you all i will see you
soon and have an excellent rest of your
day